ANANT SHUKLA: Hello, everyone.
Thank you all for
being here today.
We have a bit of Bollywood
here in New York City.
Today's-- yes, yes,
big round of applause.
Today's guest requires
no introduction.
He's an acclaimed actor,
director, singer-songwriter,
producer, humanitarian,
global icon.
After co-founding
Exile Entertainment,
he made his directing
debut in 2001
with Dil Chahta Hai, which I'm
sure everyone here has watched.
He has starred in classics,
such as "Rock On!!,"
"Zindagi Na Milegi
Dobara," "Dil Dhadakne Do,"
and most recently, "Wazir."
He was recognized with the
Filmfare Award for his best
actor performance
"Bhaag Milkha Bhaag."
But his accomplishments outside
of cinema are equally of note.
He started the MARD campaign,
which he'll talk about today,
to bring attention to the
important issue of gender
equality and violence against
women and girls in India.
In 2014 he was selected as the
first male UN Women Goodwill
Ambassador for South
Asia, has been active
part of the HeForShe campaign.
A true global icon, a
true global change maker,
please give a warm
welcome, Mr. Farhan Akhtar.
So Farhan, welcome to Google.
FARHAN AKHTAR:
Thank you very much.
Hi, hello.
ANANT SHUKLA: How does it feel?
FARHAN AKHTAR: It feels good.
ANANT SHUKLA: Feels good?
Feels good.
So we're going to talk a little
bit about your background,
career, and how that
kind of shaped then
your creative
process, and then get
into a little bit
about MARD and some
of the other social initiatives
that you're involved with.
So you grew up in a
family that's always
been involved with Bollywood.
So tell me about your
journey as an actor.
Did you always know that
acting was in the cards?
Or what kind of drew you
then to the cinema industry?
FARHAN AKHTAR: I think from
pretty much from a young age,
we have a basic idea of
where we'd like to end up,
which world we'd
like to belong to.
And I always fancied
entertaining people.
So whenever there were
guests over I would always
do things to make them
laugh, and so I'd just
get a certain degree of
attention, I guess, as a kid.
So my parents pretty
much knew that he's
going to go into film
from that time onwards.
And when you're watching
movies or you listen to music,
you very rarely know what's
going on behind the scenes.
Like now I've come to
this amazing office
that you all have, and you
see the amount of people
who put stuff together.
When you're just
using something,
it's just really what you see.
You don't know what all
goes into the making of it.
So you just know the actor.
You know the singer.
You don't know all the other
people behind the scenes,
so you're automatically
drawn to wanting
to be that person, because that
represents the film for you.
So on that level, yeah, I think
I always wanted to be in film.
I always wanted to,
at that point I guess,
be an actor, because I didn't
know what else you could do.
But then, of course,
as you start working,
you start realizing there's
many more things that
put a film together,
and sometimes even more
important than just being the
face of the film, so to speak.
And that's when the whole
acting-direction thing.
ANANT SHUKLA: Yeah,
I've heard this story
about when you were in
college that you kind of went
on a binge Netflix, back
in the day with VHS,
just watching movies.
FARHAN AKHTAR: There
was no Netflix.
There was no net.
So you had to just
flick videocassettes
from other people.
But yeah, whatever I
could get my hands on.
My mom was a very avid collector
of movies, so that helped.
So when she was awake
I'd watch the ones that
were rated good for me as a
kid, and after she'd fall asleep
I'd go into the
other drawer which
had all the adult films that I
couldn't access at that time.
But yeah, I've
watched everything,
and I've watched them
over and over again.
And I was just very
fascinated by it,
and I would just imitate
certain things of performances
that I liked.
And I was very into the
whole gangster thing, films
like "Untouchables" or
then the "Godfather" films.
De Niro doing the classic,
the American-Italian mobster.
So I used to do that a
lot with all my friends,
like, "you talking to me?
You talking to me?"
All that kind of stuff, and,
"you got nothing, nothing."
I still love all that stuff.
So yeah, just constantly
watching films.
ANANT SHUKLA: So
then that transition
from director to actor.
Obviously a change in mindset,
a change in technique.
What was most difficult there?
Or did it naturally come from
so many years of just absorbing,
watching your idols, mentoring?
What kind of--
FARHAN AKHTAR: Yeah, I think so.
Apart from, of course,
watching performances of actors
that you do appreciate
and respect,
also working with them.
I directed three films before
I started acting myself.
So working closely
and, fortunately,
with actors who really
know what they're doing.
So be it [INAUDIBLE], be it Mr.
[? Bachan ?] in [? "Luch," ?]
be it Shah Rukh in "Dawn."
So I worked with a huge--
with Priyanka, [? Pradeep ?].
So when you're working
with all these people,
you see how they
approach, and everyone
comes with questions,
comes with research,
what it is that
they'd like to do,
mannerisms that
they'd like to adopt.
So it teaches you
as well about if you
were to do that job, what it
is you-- how you approach it,
and what you could be doing.
So I felt pretty comfortable
with doing "Rock On!!"
at the time, in 2008.
Also, it was a world that
was very familiar to me.
It was set in Mumbai.
It was about music
that I enjoyed,
so I kind of slipped into
that film very easily.
ANANT SHUKLA: Then
Excel kind of has
the motto of contemporary
Indian cinema,
not your traditional
Bollywood love story.
Your movies are all
a little different.
So what, for you, is
contemporary Indian cinema,
and what are you aspiring
to then in your films?
FARHAN AKHTAR: I
don't know if there's
a standard definition of
what that is, because it's
constantly evolving.
It's constantly changing.
And I think the
important thing, if you
want to meet
contemporary film, I
think is just to keep
your ear on the ground
and kind of get a sense
of what's going on.
Every year there are
films that come out
that kind of
redefine storytelling
in the Indian film milieu.
So it's just to keep
looking out for what's
changing, what people
are reacting to,
and then try and find
stories or ideas that
could keep pushing
it in this direction
that story changing
is headed in.
ANANT SHUKLA: That
kind of segues then
into your creative process.
So for you then, how
do you sit down--
I know you've sometimes talked
about pegging onto a character
and then identifying and
building a story around that.
Is there a different
creative process
as an actor versus your role
as a producer versus a role
as a director, and
what for you allows
you to just sit down,
concentrate and then
envision the final product?
FARHAN AKHTAR: If you
really think about it--
as a director, when anybody
asks you, what do you do?
You're actually not
really doing that much,
if you think about it.
You hire, hopefully,
people who know their jobs,
and you're just telling
them yes and no to things
that they're bringing to you.
So it really is just
keeping an overview
of what you want the film to
feel like, and on some level,
being probably the first
audience to the movie.
So it's like just
watching a scene play out
as you would on screen,
but just keeping in mind
that you have in your head how
it's going to come together.
So it's really a job of just
giving people confidence,
motivating them, inspiring
them to do their best,
and just taking whatever it
is that once you brought them
into that place, where they feel
like family, where they feel
like everyone is given the
freedom and the confidence
to contribute, because
everyone does want to do that.
I've worked on certain sets
when I was an assistant director
where you didn't have the
liberty at all to go and share
what it is that maybe you
want to contribute to a scene,
because you're too low down
in the ranks to say anything.
And that troubled me.
That will always stay with me.
And I'm sure every
single person who
works in a film, so be
it the camera department,
be it the costume head,
makeup, whoever it is,
and then you expect the ideas
to come from your cameraman
and from the actors.
But everyone has hearts.
And a good example
of that is when
we were doing "Dil Chahta Hai."
So we were all thinking of how
do we shoot [? Save ?] song.
We had a really nice
song, and I didn't
want to get into
that classic lip sync
where these two characters
just suddenly get up
and start dancing.
So Arjun Bhasin, who was the
costume director on the film,
he said, why don't
they just go for a film
and then watch this
thing on a movie
and just imagine
themselves in the film.
And that's how it came together.
Now if this had happened on
the set that I was on earlier,
there's no way the costume
director could have come up
and said that idea
to a director.
So it's really important
to keep your ears,
mind open, because these ideas
can really come from anywhere.
ANANT SHUKLA: So you don't
envision then start to finish
and then organically
add in parts.
It's kind of for you--
FARHAN AKHTAR: Actually
when I'm writing the script,
it's very clear to me of what
it is I'd like it to be like,
and what I'd like
it to look like.
But eventually,
it's other people
who are going to do that
for you, and all you can do
is just answering questions.
And that's really what
you as a director.
As an actor, it's
very different.
You have just one
sole purpose, which
is to try and give
the best performance
that you can do and be as
clear in your head as to what
it is the director has-- and the
writer, who's the unsung hero,
I think.
Of every single piece
of content ever created,
I think the unsung
hero is the writer.
So what it is that they
are trying to create,
what was it about this character
that was so exciting for them
that even if it's a small
part and not the lead role,
has stayed in the script.
And why is this
character important.
To try and understand all of
that and then make that dream,
make that vision your own
and to be able to do it.
ANANT SHUKLA: Is there
a Hollywood actor
or other global actor-- you
know Leo does method acting,
where he really
gets into character
for months at a time--
that somebody that you
tried to emulate or see
as a role model there?
FARHAN AKHTAR: I don't think
emulation is the right word.
I think you do get inspired by
watching great work, for sure.
To be a [? force, ?] be
it Leonardo Di Caprio,
be it Christian Bale-- and for
me, I grew up watching De Niro,
and he was very inspirational
to me to want to be in film
and of course even act, I guess.
So I had the great
fortune of meeting him
on two occasions now,
and that's the only time
I found myself
completely speechless.
And I don't know what to say.
And I'm not from a
traditional family
at all, so we were never in this
culture of [INAUDIBLE] and all
that stuff.
We never did all that.
But he was the only
guy that I told myself
if I ever meet I'm going
to touch his [? feet. ?]
So he was pretty shocked,
because I saw him,
and I was like, [BOWS DOWN].
It was nice to meet him.
ANANT SHUKLA: Like
you said, your family,
you have a very special
relationship with your sister.
Do you ever find that there's
a friendly sibling rivalry
or competition between
the two of you?
Or how do you guys
continue to push each other
for such great work?
FARHAN AKHTAR: I just
lock her in the cupboard
when it really gets
[? ugly. ?] She's pretty small,
so it's easy to lift her up and
just keep her there for a bit.
Then she comes out and
tells me I'm the best again.
They put meals under the
door, and she stays there
for a couple of days.
I don't know if
you've ever met her.
If she hears me
saying this, I'm dead.
ANANT SHUKLA: It's OK.
This is going on YouTube now.
FARHAN AKHTAR: Nobody look.
There's no rivalry.
There isn't.
We have a relationship
and a bond
that's kind of way beyond that.
She was the first AD
on "Dil Chahta Hai,"
and I worked with her and
then the executive producer
of [? "Luch." ?] And then we've
been collaborating on her films
from "Luck by Chance."
So we work as a team.
It doesn't really feel like we
try to outdo each other at all,
ever.
It never happens.
ANANT SHUKLA: So
what, for you, has
been the most satisfying
and challenging film?
Commercial success
aside, for you, what
are you most proud of?
FARHAN AKHTAR: I think as a
director "Luch" was probably
the one that I
feel most proud of.
Apart from the fact that it
wasn't an easy film to make,
it took me to a world which
I wasn't familiar with.
And somehow it's easy to bring
yourself there as an actor,
because the director is
already giving you so much
that you can work with, and
the script gives you a lot
that you can work with.
Like for example, in
the [? "Milkha" ?] film,
there was so much to take from
it and then push yourself.
But to create that world and to
translate it and get everyone
to understand it
the way you want
to present it to
the audience, "Luch"
was a difficult one to do.
But I feel the way that
film came together,
the way the Army
reacted and responded
to the film when they
saw it, that made
me feel really good about that.
ANANT SHUKLA: So
MARD, Men Against Rape
and Discrimination.
So tell us a little
bit of your own words,
what was your vision
for the organization?
How did it come about?
What it means to you?
And how outside of cinema
there, four-part question,
is MARD so important.
FARHAN AKHTAR: It's
something as an emotion,
or as an emotional
response, to wanting
to do something about I
guess just the mounting
violence against women.
It was impossible
to read a newspaper
or watch the news where you
weren't subjected to something
really horrific going on in
some part of the country,
in the world, I guess,
where the sheer brutality
of certain crimes,
it just shocks you.
And you feel angry.
You feel helpless.
There's a lot of venting that
happens with your friends
in the room.
We must do something, and
then you wake up the next day,
and you get back to work.
So it just came to a point.
There were couple
of incidents that
happened back to back over
a period of about three
or four days.
There was this woman
who was molested
in [? Kohati, ?] and somebody
recorded it and put it out
on the internet,
which was horrific.
Then there was followed
by what happened
in [? Delhi. ?]
Then was followed
by what happened to a
five-year-old who was kidnapped
and abused by her neighbor.
So there were just so
many things that happened,
and it was just a feeling
of something has to be done.
And you can't just
go onto Twitter
and say, deeply anguished.
There has to be something more.
And also, I feel that where
we are and what we do,
we are so dependent on the love
and support of these people.
If it's not for them coming
and watching your work
or buying your music,
you don't have a job.
So its somehow important to, in
an organic way and not having
to force it, because it
has to come from inside,
but when you do
have that feeling
to do something where you
can make them understand
that it's everyone's problem.
And you're not isolated from it.
You don't live an insular life
where these kind of problems
don't affect you or
your family or what
you feel about their safety.
So it was all these
things that came together.
And there were a lot of people
already doing a lot of stuff
in rehabilitation of survivors
of rape, of domestic abuse,
of female trafficking.
Just there were already
many people doing that.
But there was very
little going on,
at least from what
I could gather,
in terms of reaching
out to men and getting
them to start understanding
that it's important for us
to start thinking
about what we can do,
because more often than not, the
perpetrators of these crimes,
of course, are men
more often than not.
So to somehow catch
men, young men,
boys at an age where
they're about to create
this concept in
their head of what
it is like to be a man and
the responsibility that needs
to come with that
definition of it,
because we take
from pop culture,
from just social culture, we
take impulses and reference
points from--
ANANT SHUKLA: We see
our idols doing it.
FARHAN AKHTAR:
--what to base it on.
Because nobody goes
and asks their parents,
mommy, am I a man now?
That doesn't happen.
[FOREIGN]
If you're asking
that question, OK.
So you just base
it on what you see.
So if we can somehow create
better reference points,
certain kind of values that
you can maybe feel like,
let me create these as a
blueprint or a benchmark
that I can use.
If I behave like this,
then maybe that's
a good thing to base my
concept of masculinity on.
So that's really
where it came from.
And we just started going
into colleges and schools.
And [? Anurak ?], who's
right here, I spoke with him.
And I didn't want to go and
give lectures in colleges,
because students
just switch off.
They're not interested
after like five minutes as,
fortunately, you all seem to be.
So he was like, let's
go and do some music.
Maybe we'll go do music,
because it changes
the mood that a person is in.
And then through that,
maybe just talk about
the initiative, share the poem.
We've got a song
that we've done.
Let's share all
of that with them.
So it will be an enjoyable
evening for them,
and when you've
had fun, you always
remember things that
happened that night.
So that's really how it started.
So now it's been
over three years.
We've been to colleges and
schools all across India.
We will keep going.
So that's really how
it came together,
to just give young boys and
young men a kind of a blueprint
that they could access.
ANANT SHUKLA: We've seen in
America grassroots movements,
whether it's electing the
president 2008 or Bernie
Sanders this year or
even Donald Trump.
If you start at the
grassroots level,
you can actually cause
social change in society.
So how are you engaging then
with students after the fact,
after a concert is done
or through the website.
FARHAN AKHTAR:
There is a website,
but the thing is that
it really is something
that people need to get
inspired to do themselves.
And that's what we try to do.
It's very difficult to follow
up with every single student
that you met.
But there is a website.
The thing is, what everyone
needs to understand,
and what we try and
explain to them,
that if you go out
saying that oh, I
want to change
every single person,
it's not going to happen.
But try and just
find those one or two
people who will listen to you,
because everyone does have
that, whether it's
in your family,
if you just change maybe the
way your one uncle thinks,
or maybe the domestic help
who's working in your house.
If there's a maid who works
there, the way your husband is
treating her, you can
try and understand
what she's going through.
Maybe educate her some more, get
her to start using the internet
so she can empower herself.
ANANT SHUKLA: [INAUDIBLE]
and Google it.
FARHAN AKHTAR: So various things
like that that can happen,
so that we do.
But eventually, we
just try and inspire
these people to find
it within themselves
to be able to do
stuff, because it
is-- if this was the only thing
that I did then probably I
would have had time to follow up
with people about what they do.
But it's many other things, like
with my job, with the music,
with film, and
also now two films.
So even "Dil Dhadakne
Do," where we've
tried to get a certain
idea of MARD into it
in one of the scenes, where
[INAUDIBLE] Priyanka and myself
are talking.
There's a similar thing that we
are putting a MARD related song
now into "Rock On!!
2" as well.
So film is a good
vehicle for it,
because it really
goes everywhere.
We just keep putting out content
and hoping that people just
get inspired by it.
ANANT SHUKLA: So for
you, what do you see then
as the biggest obstacle?
Obviously, some of these are
very deep rooted sentiment
and issues in India,
across the world
more broadly, around
rape, discrimination.
Like you said, you can
pull it apart, come out
and look at it from the
cinema lens, from concerts.
Technology can enable it.
Like I was mentioning before,
helping women get online.
You partnered with Google.
What do you see then as the
biggest obstacle then from you?
FARHAN AKHTAR: I think the
biggest challenge really--
I think because also
where-- the world's going
through an interesting
time, I feel.
There's an entire generation,
or a couple of generations
now, that really aren't
interested in the way
things used to be.
And I think that's where
the tension lies, is people
saying that I don't want to
follow those old rules that
would have been
around for centuries
dictated either by local
tradition, local customs
and culture, or by religion.
People don't want that.
And the minute people
are trying to step away
from that, especially when
it comes to women, who
have very clear cut,
designated rules when it comes
to the traditional
structure and patriarchy,
almost every single
religious book
has certain guidelines for what
women should and should not do.
So when you're trying
to move away from that,
there is tension.
And there are
people who want to,
of course, because
the majority still
exists within that
aspect of life right now.
So it's a power struggle.
And more often than not,
in any power struggle
the people who suffer the most
are considered the weakest
victims who can't fight
back, who don't have a voice,
whose rights are less,
whose voice can be subdued,
who physically
aren't that strong.
So you'll always see
it manifesting there,
so be it women, be it
the LGBT community,
be it even like in caste,
in certain places, or race.
It's the same thing
that goes on everywhere.
So it's like a power struggle.
The balance eventually
finds itself.
So it's just up to us to try
and accelerate that movement
as much as we possibly can,
so we arrive there faster.
So it's a process.
ANANT SHUKLA: You've partnered
with Priyanka, Ranveer,
Anushka, [? Suchin ?],
celebrities all across India.
People look at
their role models.
They look at pop culture
as their reference point.
So for you, how do you
see that celebrity status
as impacting or being a
role model for change?
FARHAN AKHTAR:
Eventually, everyone
has someone that they
look up to or someone
that they inspire outside,
of course, their family
and their parents like in this
pop culture or sporting culture
space.
Everyone has one.
And those people, even
if you don't realize it,
I think because you
are a public figure,
I think there is a certain
degree of responsibility,
I feel, that should
come with it,
because there's so many people
who get affected by what you do
or get inspired or get let
down by things that happen
and when you see that
happening all the time.
So if somehow you
can be aware of it,
you can't force
someone to be that way.
Eventually, it's
completely their choice
what they want to be
remembered as and for.
But if you can somehow
find that within you
and somehow find a
way to inspire people
to be more positive about
any aspect of their life,
I think it's a good
thing to try and do.
ANANT SHUKLA: I mentioned
before, obviously UN Goodwill
Ambassador taking
MARD then out to
the next international
and global level,
working with HeForShe.
What other kind of international
movements or organizations
are you hoping to partner
with through MARD,
or how will your
work with the UN
hopefully take this message
to a more global level,
and hopefully bring
change even here in the US
where some of the same
sentiments are held?
FARHAN AKHTAR: We will see.
There's constantly
something going on,
and our emphasis really has
been on content creation.
That's really what we
said we want to do.
We want to create music.
I want to get into
creating short films.
And like I said, bringing
things into feature films
as and when it's possible
to bring stuff in.
Hopefully get into doing
some kind of art as well.
But that's really the area
that I want to focus on
and then everything
that comes with it,
any kind of associations
and collaborations
that can happen on that front.
We're always open to.
ANANT SHUKLA:
Always open, great.
We're going to open it
up to audience questions,
as well, if people want
to start queuing up.
You mentioned in "Rock On!!
2" that there's another song
coming that also has MARD.
Can you talk a little bit more
about what we can expect there?
I know you can't disclose
too much information now,
but what can we
expect there, in terms
of MARD and this campaign?
FARHAN AKHTAR: Well,
it's a song that
really talks about-- it's really
like a call to action for women
to rise up, and that this
is their time and maybe all
together.
We all want to fight
for your rights.
So it's that kind of a song.
It's called "Jagu", is
what the song is called.
And it's as much a call, of
course, to the establishment,
or to the patriarchy,
that it's time
to wake up and realize
that things are not
going to be the same anymore.
ANANT SHUKLA: And
I know you just
finished the US tour as well.
Did you find the message
resonated as well here
in the US, or what most
surprised you about audiences
here when you're carrying
the MARD message?
FARHAN AKHTAR: I just
like the fact when you go,
there's all these seats out
front, and everyone comes.
And I don't know what they are
expecting this concert to be.
So we had to just
keep telling them
like, I'm sure many people have
come here and performed before,
but this is not that
kind of concert.
So please get ready to
stand up, dance, jump.
And it was great
because they all got up,
and they all had
a fantastic time.
And I'm really
glad that they all
want us to come back
and do some more music.
So we'll come back soon.
And maybe we should do a
performance here the next time.
ANANT SHUKLA: Yes, I'm sure
the audience would love that.
FARHAN AKHTAR: We do
a little unplugged set
right in the stool.
AUDIENCE: Thank you, Farhan.
I'm [? Shuwetha. ?]
Than you for joining us.
Big fan of your work,
and Zoya's as well,
and of course, [INAUDIBLE].
So when you were speaking
about MARD, I love the idea.
It's great.
But you spoke about how we
are inspired by Bollywood,
and let's face it, some
of the item numbers
are just atrocious.
And I have a soon
to be four-year-old,
and she's listening to
songs like, [INAUDIBLE]
And this is Kareena
Kapoor dancing to this.
How do we start changing
Bollywood and the way
we think about women in
music and what we see on TV?
FARHAN AKHTAR: I think
firstly, you should really
change the channel.
AUDIENCE: The
problem is it's also
the songs that you
listen to, because she's
dancing somewhere--
FARHAN AKHTAR: And I don't
mean this with any disrespect
whatsoever, but there is
a parental responsibility
as well.
Also, the fact is what
your child watches,
and what your child listens
to, you have to be aware of it.
It would be impossible
for me to tell anyone,
don't make the song, or don't
put this song in your film.
It won't be possible.
But when we realize
that people--
when people stop
listening to it,
downloading it, when
they realize that there's
not enough people buying
the song anymore,
they'll stop making it.
AUDIENCE: So how do we influence
that, because sitting over
here, it's hard
for us to do that.
And trust me, I
change the channel.
She doesn't get to
listen to the stuff.
But when you're out,
and you know every movie
has an item number,
most of them.
Are you speaking to
people in Bollywood
and trying to influence
change there as well?
FARHAN AKHTAR: We've had
conversations about this,
but it really is very
difficult, because you're
in an artistic environment.
You're in a creative field.
And the minute you're going to
get into [INAUDIBLE] someone
and telling them,
you cannot do this,
it opens up too many doors of
then other people telling you
what you can and cannot do.
So it becomes a problem.
But what we do try
is in our own films
we try our best not to do it.
So that if whoever
gets [INAUDIBLE] film
can work without having a song
like this, that's really--
and then I love directors.
There are many other people,
so be it Rakeysh Mehra, be it
[? Ashutush ?] Kuvalikul,
a lot of people--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
that came out recently.
FARHAN AKHTAR: Yeah, absolutely.
So they don't really
enjoy putting songs
like that in their film.
And there are some
people who do.
But I really feel that is
something for the audience
to reject.
You have to reject it.
If they don't reject
it, there will always
be people making that stuff.
If somebody's buying,
somebody will sell.
AUDIENCE: Well, hopefully the
boys who are speaking to girl
have been rejected, and
then we won't have to.
[?
FARHAN AKHTAR: Essentially ?].
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm Sanjay.
It's a pleasure to
meet you, big honor.
You mentioned something
that was interesting,
and I've been thinking
about it a lot as well.
So my mom and dad
watched "Aradhna"
and [? "Shoy" ?] like 15, 16
times at the movie theater.
That type of behavior
doesn't occur as much
anymore with the new generation,
at least in the United States.
Maybe it does in India.
I'm not privy to it.
But I'm curious the
platform of cinema,
does it shout in the same
way that it did back then?
And if it doesn't,
then what other mediums
are now on the rise?
FARHAN AKHTAR: I do feel that
it resonates the same way,
but I feel the way
people are experiencing
a movie now has changed.
When you talk
about your parents,
or I talk about even
when I was a teenager,
I really had not
much of a choice
apart from going to a theater
to watch a film, which
is why films ran for
50 weeks, 100 weeks,
because if you
wanted to watch it,
you had to go to the theater.
I know people who watched
"Zindagi Na Milegi Dobara"
75 times, once in the theater.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
FARHAN AKHTAR: Thank you.
I would much rather [INAUDIBLE]
75 times to a theater in
[INAUDIBLE].
So then they're like, but
I bought a ticket once,
and now I watch
it on my computer.
And I'm like, OK, what fun.
So people do watch
it, and there are
certain films that resonate with
people, that stay with people.
The message of that
movie stays with people.
The entertainment of certain
films stays with people.
So that experience, in terms
of what a person is feeling,
is exactly the same, but it's
just how they're doing it
I think has changed
tremendously.
AUDIENCE: And from a
financials perspective,
the margin on a ticket
sale in a movie theater
is much higher than
that of digital.
FARHAN AKHTAR:
Unfortunately, they've
still not cracked this whole
penalty for piracy in India
just yet.
The day a film releases
you can find pirated DVDs
and VCDs of it being
sold on the streets,
and that's where it
really, really hurts.
They did a little bit of a
study maybe about 10 years ago,
where they really tried to
see if they could control it
for the opening
weekend of the film.
And the difference of
business was almost anywhere
between 40% to 60% of a
weekend is lost on piracy.
So I don't know why
people aren't doing more
to try and control it
actually, to be honest.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
FARHAN AKHTAR: Sorry?
FARHAN AKHTAR: Yeah,
I'm sure it would.
That's also an ongoing battle
because the producers don't
decide the price of a ticket.
That is the theater
owner's, their chain.
And eventually, if you
have to release your film,
those are the people you go to.
So there are many
problems like this.
There are problems in
terms of percentage sharing
between the producer and the--
Here, it's a standard
50/50 percent
that goes between the studio
and the theater chain.
In India, it keeps changing.
You get 50% only in
the first weekend.
Then it goes down to some 42%.
Then it goes down to 35%.
Then it's at 20 some percent.
So actually for film,
if it's doing well,
and if it has long
legs, you actually
end up making a lot less
than you would have.
So if a film opens to,
say, a 50% collection,
and everybody's like,
you must go see it.
You must go see it.
By the time it comes
to the second weekend,
we are making a lot less, and
the theater's making a lot
more.
So there are many issues like
that, but I do agree with you.
I do feel that the ticket
prices are a bit much,
and they probably
force a lot of people
to stay out of the theater.
I do agree with you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hey, Farhan.
This is Oshaf.
I'm really honored to meet you.
I'm one of your
biggest fans actually.
FARHAN AKHTAR: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: And you've been
directing movies, acting,
singing.
I just have a two-part question.
So the first part, you
played Milkha Singh in one
of the movies,
"Bhaag Milkha Bhaag."
And I just wanted to ask you the
experience you had making it,
because it must be
really difficult.
And looking at your
performance, it was amazing.
So what did you do to
prepare for that role?
Did you talk to
Milkha Singh, and how
did you come about with it?
FARHAN AKHTAR: I spent
probably three days with him
before I got into
prep on that film.
And then when I realized what
his life was like, what all he
had to do, and
understood what it
is that I'd have to kind
of put myself through
to be able to look
like an athlete,
I contacted the first VFX
house that I could find.
And said, I just
wear a green suit.
Give me a body.
I was very inspired
by his story,
and there was something
that unlocked in my head.
And I just felt
like whatever needs
to be done to get this
right, I should do.
So at no point in that film did
I ever feel like it's too much.
At no point did I ever
feel like giving up.
At no point did I
ever feel like, man, I
can't do this anymore.
That feeling just never,
ever came no matter
what we were doing.
Like I was running around like
a lunatic in [INAUDIBLE] running
up hills and coming down.
We shot all the races in
Delhi in the summertime,
because that's the only time
you can get the stadiums,
because nobody goes there.
You have to be
mental to go there.
It's like 45, 46 degrees.
But we could only
shoot at that time,
because that's when the
stadiums were empty.
So to run around there for
like-- we were there 24 days
straight shooting races.
But none of it mattered,
because I was just
possessed by his story.
I think that's
really what happened.
And how it came
together, I don't know.
I don't know how to explain
it to you, apart from the fact
that I was just a bit
possessed at that time
with wanting to get it right.
AUDIENCE: My second question.
So you first directed
your first movie,
which was "Dil
Chahta Hai," which
set a benchmark in good movies
for the whole generation--
for example, my
generation from the 90s--
and the last time we
saw a movie from you
was "Dawn 2," which was 2011.
When are we going to
get to see you come
back in a director's seat next?
FARHAN AKHTAR: Soon, I guess.
It's something that
I do enjoy doing.
What's happening right now in
my life, apart from the music,
is also there's like
a wonderful flow
to the work that's happening
of working with directors
whose movies I've enjoyed, with
on-scripts that I won't get
to work on as a director,
because somebody else is making
it.
So it's nice also to be a part
of another person's vision.
And I feel when I
don't get inspired
by what's happening within
the acting world that's
being offered to me, I'll
just go back and start
directing again.
AUDIENCE: Are you
hinting you you're
going to make "Dawn 3" soon?
FARHAN AKHTAR: Oh, is that
the-- --the secret question.
Can you [INAUDIBLE].
It was a last restraint.
When I run out of acting
work, I'll let you know.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so
much for coming here.
FARHAN AKHTAR: And thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Farhan.
This is [? Nihadika ?].
Thank you so much, actually,
for taking the time
to be here today.
FARHAN AKHTAR: It
was my pleasure.
AUDIENCE: My question was you
mentioned that you're actually
going to colleges
and talking to kids
and enlightening them
about the entire HeForShe
kind of situation.
But in my experience,
what's really happening is
there's a certain perception
formed between 10 to 15 years
or so, when the
kids are that young.
And like somebody
already mentioned,
thanks to the songs
that come out,
thanks to so many Bollywood
movies in the theater,
and generally because probably
less parental guidance,
there is already a
certain perception
by the time they
come to college.
So do you think that maybe
we need to focus more
on schools and that age kids?
Would that have a bigger impact?
And I don't know.
I was just wondering if
you're already doing that?
FARHAN AKHTAR: You
know it probably would.
But it would have to come then
in the form of the education
that they're receiving already.
Maybe even like stories that
kids are taught at a young age,
if they can focus on not the--
AUDIENCE: But in a lot of
these government schools,
they don't have the
privilege to that.
So a lot of Indian schools,
which are not private,
essentially, may not
have the same privilege.
Or if you go to
public schools, you
don't have that
kind of education.
So maybe you're going
there and actually
having these kind of songs
at that age would actually
have a bigger
impact and actually
have a more cultural change
in that generation, so to say.
So they actually started
looking at it differently.
[INAUDIBLE] was actually
probably doing it at an elder
age, I'm just thinking of--
FARHAN AKHTAR: Yeah,
by the time we're
talking to kids who are
actually 15, 16, because that's
when they get into college.
So that's when we,
more often than not,
end up engaging with them.
But there's also a lot of
stuff going on in schools, even
government run programs that
are going on in schools.
There's the whole
[INAUDIBLE], that's
happening that's
created its own-- that
affects the syllabus,
to a certain extent,
in terms of what
all is being taught.
So these things are going on.
At the end of the
day, we are people who
wherever we're invited, we go.
It's that kind of a thing.
But I would imagine in
school and from a young age,
I think what you
teach kids would
be important in the
form of storytelling.
I think that would work very,
very effectively if they
were still little.
There was a book that had
come out a little while
ago, which was like fairy tale
but not politically correct.
It was quite interesting,
where Goldilocks
saves the world from the
hunter, things like that.
So it teaches you
a different kind--
it's not always a
damsel in distress,
and some prince needs
to come and save her.
So those kind of stories
where you create girl heroes
and women heroes
for children so it's
not always the one who
needs to be rescued,
or the one who's weaker.
I think that would
really, really
help if that could come
into school at a young age.
AUDIENCE: Your short stories
that you were mentioning,
your shadow videos.
FARHAN AKHTAR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: The shadow
videos that you
were mentioning that
you're doing right now,
the short films.
FARHAN AKHTAR: What we're doing
with the short films right
now is that we're
focusing on female icons,
and we are kind of wanting to
reverse that philosophy that
exists of behind
every successful man,
there is a woman.
We want to change that to
beside every successful woman,
there's also a man.
So that's what we want to do.
And talk about the men in
the lives of successful women
and the part that
they play, so men also
feel good about that
kind of contribution.
I don't always have
to be the one who's
the hero and the
star in the family.
So even if my wife is, or my
sister is, or my daughter is,
there's a lot of pride and a
lot of joy and a lot of success,
even for me withing
that happening.
So let me maybe help
them achieve their dreams
and not be the one
that has to do it,
because I'm the
man in the family.
So that's what we're
focusing on right now.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Farhan.
I wanted to thank you as well,
with everyone here, for coming.
So my question is more
so what you personally
want to see from an
institution like Google
to help prevent the
violence against women
and specifically-- I know
you're the UN Ambassador
for a women in South Asia.
Do you work at all for Pakistan?
So personally, I'm half
Pakistani, half Indian.
And I'm going to be working
on YouTube in Pakistan
in the coming months.
So I'm just curious
what you personally
want to see from the South
Asian region, including
Pakistan and India from Google?
FARHAN AKHTAR: What
would I like to see?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, what
do you personally
think that we, as
an institution,
should do to prevent the
violence against women.
Anything that we can do.
FARHAN AKHTAR: Well, it's a very
difficult question to answer,
because culturally, there are so
many problems wherever you go.
Each place has its own issues.
Although on some
level, culturally,
India and Pakistan
are very similar.
But then again, I
guess on the basis
of there are certain issues that
come with certain religions,
I guess, of having
to be a certain way.
And I feel challenging
those ideologies, I think,
is probably the biggest
challenge that any country that
is founded on any principles
of religion faces.
So I think that's possibly
Pakistan's biggest challenge is
how to counter that,
because there's a lot
of do's and don'ts that comes
in being part of a certain
culture.
And I think that's
the big challenge.
So what you can do?
I'm sure you have a hundred
ideas that you could enlighten
me with, and if
there's any way that I
can help you get those ideas out
further and reach more people,
I'd be glad to.
AUDIENCE: Specifically
then for India,
what do you think that we can
do, besides just awareness,
to help prevent the
violence against women?
FARHAN AKHTAR: I
think education.
I think really the
important thing,
the answer lies in education
and in educating kids and just
getting them to understand basic
values, just basic human values
at a young age.
And if we can do that, and
that has to come into-- like we
were just discussing--
whether it's
from a young age in the stories,
or how a family treats the girl
child vis a vis the boy
child at home, the freedoms
that you give them.
And all these things,
eventually, there
will be a generational
change, and the people
who are too far gone, no,
to try and change them.
So let's forget about them.
But the ones who are
coming, and the ones
who will be now
leaders in their fields
and the opinion
makers of tomorrow,
those people have to grow
up with a different mindset
from the ones before them.
And that can really, really
only happen through education.
So whether you put
out-- whatever it is.
Everyone now is on their
phone, is on a tablet,
is on their computer--
ANANT SHUKLA: Social media.
FARHAN AKHTAR: --so whatever
you can put out there
to help educate them to
be able to understand this
in an engaging way, in
an entertaining way, that
creates dialogue,
that creates curiosity
about wanting to
know more, I think
that's really where the
challenge lies for all of us
to keep doing that, because
that's the only way I
know that it can happen.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: My name is Anita.
I am just--
FARHAN AKHTAR: Ma'am, there is
something really troubling me
on both sides.
Can I just come
and fix that mic?
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
FARHAN AKHTAR:
Thank you so much.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[FOREIGN]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
FARHAN AKHTAR: It's
easier to adopt
something that's bad for you.
AUDIENCE: And you make it--
FARHAN AKHTAR: No, but
that's-- if you just take any
[INAUDIBLE], if you
take smoking, drinking.
[FOREIGN]
ANANT SHUKLA: Last
audience question.
AUDIENCE: So hi, this is Anthra.
So my name is Anthra.
I'm great fan of yours.
So you have played
multiple roles in movie,
but which one is the one that
is closest to your heart?
Being actor, singer,
director, producer-- do I?
No?
FARHAN AKHTAR: I can't-- I
don't know how to answer that
question.
I really don't.
I've been asked this question
since the last eight years.
I still don't have
an answer for it.
It keeps changing
also, in all honesty.
But eventually, at
the end of it all,
it's all about
engaging with people.
It's all about
entertaining people,
and hopefully getting
them to do good things.
So it's very difficult
to say which one.
I, too, I enjoy all of it.
And the minute I stop
enjoying [? doing ?]
film, I'll stop doing it.
So that's [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: I feel like your
ideas are really important,
and I've learned a lot today.
Do you have any intention
in making a film geared
towards the American audiences?
FARHAN AKHTAR: I don't really
think of film like that,
to be honest with you.
What happens is,
as an artist, you
get excited by either what's
offered to you as a script,
or then an idea that you have.
And on some level,
we are, I guess,
bound by the constraints,
for whatever it's worth,
at least in the
mainstream in India,
by the language that we
have to make our film in.
So there's a certain
challenge that
comes with taking that
across to an audience that
maybe would watch it if it
was an hour, hour an a half.
But our films tend to be longer.
They do.
That's a fact.
Also, culturally different
because of the song and dance.
So it becomes somehow maybe
not taken as seriously
because of that aspect of it.
But the hope really is that
it could reach out to anyone.
We watch foreign language
films all the time.
We watch them with
subtitles, and at no point
do we feel like,
oh, I don't want
to watch that film because it's
in Korean, or it's in Spanish,
or it's in English.
You don't feel like you
don't want to watch it.
So hopefully we can excite
people to watch our films
for what they are.
And it's of course
an understanding
that you'd want it to have some
substance that could resonate
with those people.
That I do understand
and appreciate.
But I feel that a film
like "Zindagi Na Milegi
Dobara," for example, I feel
that if marketed correctly
to a viewer that does not speak
Hindi, it would affect them.
It would influence them.
They'd enjoy that film.
So the challenge of marketing
it then lies with somebody else.
And hopefully that is
something that we can track,
because that is an area I feel
that Hindi films have still
not found they feed on, on how
to make it exciting for people
who are not Indian, or
not from the sub-Continent
to be able to come in
and enjoy their work.
ANANT SHUKLA: Great,
so last question.
Favorite dialogue from a
movie or a poem, a few words
to leave us with.
FARHAN AKHTAR: Good
[? shot. ?] So I
guess I'll leave you all with
maybe the MARD poem, since we
will hear about that.
So this is what we
really go around,
and when we talk about a
blueprint for the new man is--
[FOREIGN]
ANANT SHUKLA: Ladies and
gentlemen, Mr. Farhan Akhtar.